mookie betts a little bit of a sore back
we are told he's going to get the day
off and of course bellinger out of the
lineup bitching for the athletics is
jesus lazardo and i think for every
start that he makes it's a learning
process for him
and all it takes is to have success and
one of those starts and let's hope that
is today against the dodgers there's no
two walks two strikeouts here's aj
pollock that's a base hit in the center
field for aj pollock gloriano has a can
and taylor can really fly and he was
moving to the crack of the bat they
waste no time jumping in front aj
pollock with a first inning rbi single
and it's one nothing for aj pollock put
on a terrific swing on a ball that was
inside about 97 miles an hour and the
batter pollock has been relatively quiet
but not this afternoon
four seamer caught a lot of the plate
and [ __ ] got some barrel on it
knocked it straight up the middle trevor
bauer and his dodger debut struck out
ten against the rockies switch hitting
second baseman jed lowry standing in
from the left side and lowry strokes one
into right field backpedaling is
mckinstry leaps up and makes a
one-handed catch
lowry thought he might have beaten
mckinstry mckinstry caught up to the
baseball made the catch two down more
than two for 16 signed as a free agent
in february and this one is lined right
toward second base where justin turner
is playing in the shift and he makes the
grab for the out
five at 4 m
line drive nice play the ball had some
serious spin on it was curving
back-to-back base runners after bow
retired the first five and bauer is set
to face the shortstop elvis andrews got
him with a fastball in the outside
corner at 95.
borderline pitch went bauer's way
average doesn't agree and he's now over
his last 21.
so bauer with a second punch out of the
afternoon leaves two runners garcia then
back to the top of the order canna and
lowry to up against trevor bauer
curveball taken for strike three
just absolutely froze garcia and bauer
has his third strike out of the game
power set to face marcana for the second
time strike three call getting all kinds
of help from dan molina
this is definitely a gift
now he faces lowry switch hitter batting
left breaking ball swinging a miss
strike three lowry out on strikes power
strikes out the side hays are down one
to nothing and hazel cesaro back to work
against the bottom third of the dodger
lineup he flies one to left again high
in the air back goes brown toward the
wall with the win who knows settling on
the track reaches up he got it
seth brown staying with it on a very
tough day for the outfielders sunshine
and wind leaves his feet right at the
wall
and may have stolen a home run on a
win-swept day from austin barnes one out
and a tip of the cap from jesus lizardo
pretty good season debut for seth brown
still just one hit against him and it
came from the guy that's standing up now
seth brown now he's 90 feet closer to
tying the game
[Applause]
[Music]
ball just gets away from smith to try to
backhand the ball foot race mariana wins
the time game something brewing for the
dodgers second and third now two outs
and around defunct punts it toward third
in the shift nobody's there chapman
receives the ground ball and makes a tag
on the runner going to third
but did the run score ahead of that
now they're going to discuss this the
two umpires
[Applause]
and the run scores
and they had to discuss it
on a ground ball and a little
butt attempt against a shift
toward the third base side by mckinstry
and chapman able to
field the ball
five unassisted at third base
but muncie was able to touch home plate
before the tag was applied by chapman on
the bag at third and that's how the
dodgers take a two to one lead as we go
to the bottom of the sixth back to back
outs after the lead off man reached
pitch to moreland he pops it up
and looking forward out in front of home
plate will smith but max muncie comes in
and calls him off first baseman with a
better angle he makes the catch to
retire the side inning over
and we move to the seventh so two on
nobody out and justin turner coming up
he gets one to hit here yanks it on a
line to left it's over the head of brown
taylor's in the score they'll stop
seeger at third and a double from justin
turner and they lead 3-1
you can hold this offense down for a
while but here early in the season with
the 5-1 record
five out of six games they've gotten 10
or more hits they're scoring runs at
about a seven run a game clip
it is hard to hold them down right now
somebody's gonna get you bauer's still
out there 90 pitches into this game and
now here's chapman he's over two he has
struck you out and popped a short
chapman that's from
[Applause]
his first water ball of the year
a welcome sight indeed
he's back within a run they trail three
to two folks sometimes the best remedy
for a rough start is to take a little
trip a little vacation you know put your
feet up
take advantage of what's been given to
you and right here
matt chapman gets a cookie and if it
stays fair it's gone and it was
pack your bags folks all aboard next
stop
pound town
the bullpen is ready dave roberts looks
like he's sticking with trevor bauer
right now
[Applause]
dave roberts
coming out a very fine performance by
trevor bauer sixth and two-thirds
innings gives up two runs three hits
with the ten strikeouts he's not giving
up an earned run one for one and save
opportunities in 2021 we'll take over
here to try to save this one for trevor
bauer is down three two one out second
and third bottom of the ninth and now
for elvis he has to make kata that is
goal number one right here with the
infield back elvis has to drive to right
center field coming on taylor is there
he makes the catch tagging his chapman
comes to the plate here's the throw the
tag in
the ball gets away and it's backed up by
jansen
and the a's have tied the game
it's a sac fly chapman scores holding
its second is tom it's a 3-3 game in the
bottom of the ninth norland is the
hitter one of the new athletics trying
to be a hero
that should do it taylor's not going to
get it cannon's gonna trot home and the
a's are gonna walk it off for their
first win of the 2021
season so they get a run in the night a
run in the 10th and they get to
celebrate and it's been a while waited a
little longer than we all had hoped